we're asked to graph the proportional
relationship shown in the table below
and they give us a table of XY values
and the corresponding Y values so we see
when X is equal to zero Y is equal to
zero and then they give us a bunch of
other points when X is three Y is zero
point five when X is 6 Y is one so on
and so forth so let's graph one of these
that actually have integer values for
both coordinates so when X is 6 when X
is 6 Y is 1 so we only need two points
to specify the line so we've actually
graphed it but they also ask us what is
the slope of this line and we just have
to remind ourselves our slope is what is
our change in Y for given change in X so
for example or you another way to think
about what is your change in Y over your
change in X so here our X changed by 6
and went from 0 to 6 and our Y changed
by 1 so our change in Y over our change
in X which is the definition of slope
our change in Y is 1 when our change in
X is 6 see that right over here change
in Y 1 when our change in X is 6 let's
check our answer we got it right